happy father's day and welcome to the
broadcast left-hander alex young out
there today
27 appearances his first start came last
tuesday
four innings and a no decision in san
francisco he gets the start here today
one down for pollock who's hitting 252
on the air
he heard the shortstop backhanded by
mick what a play
what a play by nick ahmed
know your runner nick ahmed knows that
aj pollock can still scoop down that
line so he wastes
absolutely no time in and out of the
glove
throwing back across his body right on
the money to as drupal cabrera
tip of the cap from his teammates two on
and two out for
andy burns young with pitch number 22
coming up here on the opening frame the
pitch to
burns is grounded to short ahmed's got
it and nick throws to first and he gets
him
and the sides retired without any damage
two inch two left
tony gonzalon who makes his third start
81 pitches on monday's last timeout
eduardo escobar of course's 62 minutes
are the gold standard of ineptness
that year they went 40 and 120 and two
games were mercifully rained out
so they were the worst team from 1900 on
in baseball
and a fly ball into short center field
chris taylor
is in to make the catch and that's going
to do it two on and one out for
turner who's single to center his first
time up here's a 2-1
turner finds a base head into center
field
taylor will come around to score and the
dodgers take a one to nothing lead
and here comes albert pooh holtz who's
single to right in his first at-bat
one two is hit well down the left-field
side
it has gone a home run career home run
673 for the machine
a three-run shot of the dodgers lead at
four-nothing
four-nothing and again it sounds like a
home game for the dodgers
steven souza jr coming up he struck out
in his first at-bat
dodgers four to nothing and he lines one
toward the right field corner that's
going to be a base hit
it gets past reddick rolls to the wall
coming around the score is burns
and arriving at third base is steven
souza
jr and the dodgers have a five to
nothing lead
and the hits just keep on coming so two
outs in the inning now the banner is
barnes who fly to right his first time
up
the one-two pitch to barnes and a swing
and a miss he's tagged out
getting over the dodgers lever runner at
third but boy they
scored they got five in the ending they
leave a runner
first and third nobody out for aj
pollock
pollock bangs one of the left center
field that's going to score godzilla
it's going to the wall taylor is going
to come all the way around
two runs batted in for pollock and the
dodgers lead it
seven nothing and the bases are loaded
for steven souza junior infielders are
back
seven nothing dodgers fourth inning
first one is grounded down to third
escobar's got it goes to sing for one
over the first double play
and the innings over i thought eduardo
was going to step on the bag and fire
across
he went five four three that'll do it
dodgers get a couple they leave a couple
escobar is driven in 44 that leads the
ball club has to do his 15 home runs
swinging a line drive and that's a hit
marta had to hold up but he'll still
come in to score the nightback's first
run of the day
on an rbi single by escobar 7-1
found the shift and he beat the shift
with that swing
looked like a split finger this ball
again was elevated
he's thrown some really good ones in
this game but this one just stayed up
is oh for one of course he hasn't had
many opportunities to come to the plate
ahmed sneaking in behind lux and
clevenger gets it down in fair territory
nicely done
and it's close at first and down goes
clevenger
[Applause]
lux will come in to score josh rojas the
second baseman lost his glove
8-1 dodgers aj pollock one for two a
walk of the run scored today coming up
another two two to aj here it comes
and he hits about the middle of base hit
barnes comes in to score it's nine to
one clevenger going first to third and
pollock will slide in safely at second
aj with another run batted in 9-1
dodgers and now the batter pulse has got
a three-run over today two for three at
the plate
imac's in danger of losing their 17th
consecutive game
swinging a fly ball to right sends
reddick back
he's there and makes the catch on the
warning track to retire pulse
martin batcher himself now with two outs
in the fifth
3-2 on corbin martin kyle schwerber with
a three-homer game today
shot to center and that ball is going to
get down for a hit
so martin singles with two men out line
single to center field
no he was a oh for three career with
three strikeouts so that's the first
major league hit for corbin martin
congratulations they'll certify that
baseball
there's reddick swinging a little flare
that's
over the head of turner excuse me the
third baseman burns
and on the play peralta will go to third
on an rbi single by reddick
to make it nine to two burns won the air
didn't get it
and runny's got an rbi single
now dalton varshall coming up nothing in
one
as varshall waits and he smacks this one
down to
burns who makes the diving grab
it wasn't a screaming line drive but
varsho
is robbed of an extra base hit
nonetheless by andy burns
and that will end the inning only good
second mckinsey at first two down to the
ending
pulse has already had a three-run over
in the spa game and he had a chance last
time up for another three run over
but was retired on a fly ball to right
oh one pitch is hit to right center
field
backing up on it is reddick and he's got
it for the out
dodger fans don't like that so he
doesn't throw the ball he throws it all
the way back
in and the inning comes to an end one
hit one walk two left we'll go to the
bottom of seventh
and the bases are loaded and coming to
the play will be josh redick
and the 2-2 and a shot to right center
that's a hit he'll score a couple send
another runner around to third it's nine
to four
a two run single by redick he's knocked
in three today with his third hit
walker comes up as a pinch hitter here
two runs into the ending there he goes
and a
line drive base hit left field to run
his end nine five ball game
cabrera scores stopping at second is
redick rbi single by walker as a pinch
hitter
little by little another base hit moves
the line
pitch to vote swinging a ground ball
down to first it's a fair ball
pitcher's not getting over there the
race is on save it first base is loaded
they are loaded for josh van meter
gonzalez brings it home
and he walked him forces home a run
it's a nine to six ball game and here
comes martay with the bases loaded
gonzalez ready first pitch swaying and a
shot to right center base hit
two are going to score the other runner
to third it's a nine to eight ball game
on a two on single by marty
how about these d-backs today on
father's day
josh rojas the hitter
two balls and one strike to josh rojas
lefty against lefty gonzalez delivers
and they get a ground ball to first
bullholes has it
and he defiantly puts his foot on the
bag to end the inning
chris taylor's got two hits today last
two times up he has struck out
rogers center fielder this afternoon
[Applause]
17 runs and 27 hits in this ball game
nine eight dodgers in the ninth there's
the ground ball down to third diving
stop van meter
gets you out at second and then the ball
is transferred
and marty drops it they call the out at
second
looked like he was reaching in and
taking the ball out to throw to first
now it's two out wouldn't you know it
the former astro josh
reddick stepping in he's got three hits
and three rbis today
dodgers nine to eight
[Applause]
yeah this should do it burns charging
underhand toss he got him
that's the ball game the dodgers sweep
the diamondbacks
they can exhale now as the diamondbacks
put six runs on him in the eighth inning
but jansen holds on he picks up
his 18th save